ERIC SEIDEL: Good morning.
It's really nice to be back.
We were here for the last
Dart summit about a year ago,
a year and a half now-.
And yeah, we got all sorts of
cool stuff to show you today.
So my name, if you don't
know me, is Eric Seidel.
I'm the manager of the
Flutter project at Google.
And if you haven't
heard of Flutter,
well, we do what
it says on the tin.
We help you build beautiful,
fast apps for iOS and Android.
And I think we can
just get right into it.
So we started out
with this mission--
to build a better way
to develop for mobile.
And you might ask yourself, why?
Or why would we need,
or want to do that?
And some of it comes
because much of my team
did mobile development
themselves,
wrote apps themselves,
before coming to Flutter.
And as we were
starting out, we talked
to a bunch of other mobile
devs, both inside and outside
of Google.
And we kept hearing sort
of the same refrains.
The most common
complaint that we heard
was that folks have
trouble with mobile.
That mobile is
expensive to them,
because they have to learn two
systems, two languages, two
frameworks, deploy to two
different kinds of devices.
And they end up building
two teams, or three, teams,
if you end up building
for the mobile web.
Or not including, of course,
your desktop and other web
teams.
And you end up, then, with
these disparate feature sets.
So your iOS version
does one thing,
and your Android
version does another.
And your users end up confused.
Another complaint
that we heard was
that even just
developing for mobile,
depending on what you're
using, can be slow.
We heard cycle times inside
Google ranging from a minute
to tens of minutes.
To, we heard about clean
builds that were over an hour.
And this can be,
obviously, expensive.
And it's also-- your user
expectations on mobile
are higher than they
were on desktop,
than they were on the web.
They expect you to
stick to their finger.
You expect the app to
dance underneath you.
And to do that sort of
delightful can be hard.
And then, of course,
you have to do it twice.
And finally, we talked
to a bunch of teams
and asked them about whether
they were using existing
cross-platform solutions.
And some of them had tried them.
But the feedback
we got there was
that they weren't willing
to accept the compromises.
And they listed things like
compromises in performance,
compromises in being able to
meet their design expectations,
or compromises in terms
of reaching their user
expectations.
The expected feel.
And so with this information,
we thought to ourselves,
I mean, come on.
We had done lots of
various other development.
We knew that there
must be a better way.
We felt that you
should be able to build
a single, unified team.
Where you have one team where
you can send all your code
reviews.
You know, one single codebase.
That you should be able to
build features only once,
and make them maybe
twice as beautiful,
with twice the people.
That custom could,
and should, be easy.
And that once you've done your
awesome custom-branded thing,
it should be portable.
And then finally, that
dev cycles could be fast.
I mean, we have this
on the web, right?
We have subsecond cycles
for some configurations.
Why can't we do that on mobile?
And so we set out
to build something.
And, well, we built
some cool stuff.
So I want to show you.
And I'm going to start
moving with this device here.
And so what I have in front
of you, as it boots up-- here
we go.
What I have in
front of you today
is an iOS and Android
app-- or, I'm sorry,
an iOS and Android phone,
not particularly new phones,
on which I've installed one
of our demo apps, the Flutter
Gallery.
We built this to show
off all the widgets
that we built for Google teams.
And the first thing you'll
notice is it's fast.
You may not have
even noticed that,
or you may not have even
seen it, it was so fast.
But it just-- boom!
Right back up.
It's fast.
It sticks to your finger.
It scrolls.
The animations are smooth.
The next thing you might
notice is that it's pretty.
Like, the text is pretty
on both iOS and Android,
different fonts.
The animations are pretty.
The widget sets are pretty.
You get a ton of widgets,
just out of the box.
And then, of course, one
thing you'll also notice
is that it should feel natural.
Like, it does the bounce on iOS.
It does the
overscroll on Android.
The iconography is different,
as you would expect.
And even the gestures
are different.
But there's one more thing,
which is particularly
applicable to this crowd.
In that everything
you've seen so far--
every pixel, every widget, every
gesture, even the compositor
and the text
editing, is all Dart.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's go back to the slides.
And we can talk a little more.
So what did we just see?
So hopefully, you got to
see, well, first of all,
that Flutter is real.
It's a thing.
It exists.
It's fast.
It, again, scrolls fast.
It animates smoothly.
It responds to your finger.
It should be pretty.
It's beautiful.
It has tons of beautiful
widgets built-in.
It does animations easily.
And it should feel
natural and be natural.
We believe strongly that
you should come to the user.
You should match
their expectations.
That if their thumb has some
muscle memory about what to do,
that that's what
your app should do.
And so we embrace
that with Flutter--
that you're not writing one
least common denominator app.
But rather, you're
writing the app
that fits the user's
expectations of the device
that it's installed on.
So we're obviously not the first
to think about cross-platform.
There's many others
in this space.
But I do think that there's a
bunch of insights that we had,
some things that we chose to
do differently, that I think
do make us special.
And the first thing
I want to talk about
is actually how we went
about building this.
So when we went to build this,
we went looking around for,
what is the technology
stack that a better
cross-platform solution
should be built on?
And we were perhaps a
little bit surprised
that it was all just lying
right in front of us.
But the difficulty was
that these awesome pieces
of technology were actually
buried deep in other platforms.
Buried under layers and layers
and layers of legacy and tons
of features that either
didn't matter on mobile,
or they didn't need anymore.
And so we went digging
for quite a while.
We went mining in the hills.
And I think we
pulled out a bunch
of really nice golden nuggets.
And this matters to
you, because this
is battle-hardened software.
This is not, you know,
from green implementation.
This is just the slimmed-down
and awesomest versions
of the platforms that you
already know and love.
So, like, we took some of our
graphics stack from Chrome,
some of our graphics
stack from Android.
We took a bunch of our text
from WebKit and Chrome.
But way, way, way
slimmed-down, as opposed
to what is in those platforms.
And, of course, we actually
started in a totally different
language.
That didn't work out so well.
We tried a couple
other languages--
those didn't work out so well.
And went on a rather
long search, in which
we found, eventually, Dart.
And we use an even slightly
slimmed-down version
of Dart inside our executable.
So the second insight that
we had in building this
was that we learned that
other platforms that
have these expansive
APIs, particularly
these cross-platform-- these
expansive API surfaces that
are often the least
common denominator,
and they're all packed
inside the engine
itself, down below the
widgets-- other platforms often
are like icebergs.
You see and deal with the
top little widget layer,
but there's so much
buried under the surface.
We tried to invert
that with Flutter.
And this matters
to you, because it
means it puts you
way more in control.
We found that dev
cared about the fact
that we had shoved all
of our interesting code
up into the framework layer.
Which meant even things that you
might not have expected here,
like editing, and our gesture
detection, and our compositor,
et cetera-- it's all up
at the framework layer.
Which means that you can,
you know, jump to definition
all the way down.
See exactly what we've done.
Fork, change-- you're
in full control.
And due to the beauty of
Dart, and Dart's ability
to tree-shake, you only
pay for what you use.
So another insight
that we had in building
this was that modern
mobile developers-- well,
modern mobile OSes
don't necessarily
need to ship a UI framework.
They do, today, obviously.
But we've seen
success on desktop,
we've seen success on the
web, that many applications
ship beautiful apps
bundling their own.
And the same is
now true on mobile.
You see this all over
the place with games.
No game uses the
built onto the ROM
system-- there is no built
onto the ROM system for games.
They all bring their
own beautiful engine
and do amazing
experiences with that.
And we found that
there was an advantage
to doing the same on mobile--
or to doing the same for apps.
And why this matters to
you, is that it puts you,
again, more in control.
You can deploy way back in time
to older phones, to older OSes.
When the tides change, and
you want to change your look
and feel, you don't
have to wait for users
to upgrade so you can
use the latest widget.
You just push them a new version
that you compiled yourself.
The next insight we had
was less about technology
and more about market shift.
We looked at what people
were doing on mobile.
We looked at what
the best apps were.
What were the apps that
were winning awards?
users were downloading?
And it turns out
there's a lot of custom.
And this is a growing
segment we see.
The best in class
user experiences
are bespoke experiences that
are very brand-forward, very
custom.
And so we decided that
we want to target this.
That we wanted to
build a system that
was designed to make this easy.
And the value for
you is, obviously,
if it does make it easy, you
can do more of this yourself.
So let's go back to that demo.
And I want to show you
that same demo, but now
with a different understanding.
So this time, we only need
to use the Android phone.
So go ahead and launch
the gallery again.
So now you understand, again,
that all of this is Dart.
Everything you see, everything
you feel, is all Dart.
And one of the cool
things you can do,
or something I'm here to do
to illustrate how custom this
really is, is that there's
a little dividing feature
we have.
Where we can change what
the framework thinks
it's running on.
And I can tell the framework,
you're running on iOS.
And now magically, you have
different scroll physics.
You have a bounce.
You have different iconography.
[APPLAUSE]
And you have cool gestures.
And I'm not telling you that you
would ever want to ship this.
Because, again, we believe
in coming to the user
and matching their expectations.
But what this is, is
an illustration to you
of how much control you have.
If you want to have a back
shimmy, you know, go for it!
The entire gesture detector
is yours to control.
So let's go do our little
shimmy between devices again.
Go back to the slides.
So that was our demos.
We are at a
developer conference,
so we should talk a little
bit about development.
I think maybe we should
show you what it's
like to develop a Flutter app.
So let's go and bust
out IntelliJ, which
is a popular editor at Google.
There's many editors that you
can write Flutter code in.
But this one happens to be nice.
So let's go ahead and
create a new project.
And we also have a Flutter
plugin for IntelliJ--
actually just
released last night.
[APPLAUSE]
Which makes some of this easier.
So we got to Flutter, and
let's make a totally rad demo.
We'll call it "Rad Demo."
And what's happening
there is that it
is going off and
telling Flutter tooling
to go create the
underlying Xcode project,
create the underlying
Android build setup.
And dump you a very
small little Flutter app.
And so now we have our
little 70-line demo Flutter
app, most of which is comments.
Which, we just click
the Run button.
And it, again, tells
the Flutter tooling,
go run this on some
connected device.
IntelliJ doesn't have to know.
And Flutter, of course,
abstracts you away
from the idea of, is this
Android, or is this iOS?
It's just a mobile thing to you.
But the mobile thing we're
going to run on today
is this iOS simulator here.
So here we have,
you know-- whatever
that was, 90 seconds in, we have
running, on iOS and Android,
our very first Flutter app.
And it just has
a little counter.
Clicks the button-- creases.
But we can make this fancier.
And that's what I
actually want to show you.
So say we don't like blue,
because we like green instead.
We'll just change it!
[APPLAUSE]
Maybe my designer
likes orange today.
I'll go back to green.
Yeah.
So we measure our development
cycle in milliseconds.
And you'll notice that
we never lost any state.
We still tapped the
button seven times.
Our app is still running.
But we can do more
complicated things.
So say we want to change this
text-- maybe this is touched.
We update the text.
You see, of course, it changes.
Maybe we want to
change the center.
We can make this a column.
We run it.
Whoops.
We made an error.
We can see in
IntelliJ, it tells us,
it's underlining this
child, saying, that is not
a valid parameter for column.
And Flutter took the
reload, but it's like, ah, I
don't know what to do.
No, I could go read the docs
to remember what Column does.
Or I could just click on Column.
Because, again, all of
our code is up on Dart.
You can keep clicking
all the way down.
We can go read and
say, oh, Column
takes "children," not "child."
Of course.
So we change this to children.
And now it's still mad at us.
The analyzer is still giving
us little red squiggles,
which we're used to in Dart.
So let's change
this to be an array.
I think that's the one I wanted.
And then, we can, of
course, reformat it.
And we run it again.
And we've still
touched it seven times.
We fixed our error.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's go ahead and add some
more text, because why not?
New text.
"Demos are fun!"
And now we have
two lines of text.
We could maybe
change the spacing.
On this, unless we can
do main axis alignment.
Spread evenly-- space evenly.
Sure, great.
Now they're all spaced out.
We could do something
a little more exciting.
We can do, like,
new Flutter logo.
Oh, that's too small.
We'll fix the size.
There we go.
Hey, well, maybe we'll
change the color.
Whoops!
Colors.
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
Obviously, you could build
much more complicated things
than that.
But that's what
Flutter development is.
And here, again, it
took us two minutes
to do this tiny
little pretty app.
But I want to show you
more than just IntelliJ.
Because maybe you don't
like working in ID.
That's fine.
Some of my team work
in Emacs or Vim.
So just like our framework
is layered, heavily layered,
we also have done
our tools in layers.
So we can pull out
our command line.
And let's up the
size a little bit.
And we have a little Flutter
tool, which, you know,
spews all the commands
that it supports.
The Flutter tool abstracts
away the idea of mobile.
So you don't have to care
about iOS or Android--
it just handles the
details for you.
So if we, like, connect
our Android device here--
so this is our physical
device we were just using.
And we say, type,
Flutter devices.
You know, Flutter now
shows us both, of course.
We also have some other
fun commands in here.
Like you can take
screenshots and do
performance profiling, and
debugging, and all that stuff.
All from the command line.
We can do Flutter Doctor.
Flutter Doctor is
something that we built,
because we found our customers
had some trouble getting
all the various pieces of
mobile development set up.
So we wrote a little
helper to help
them know how to walk
through the steps,
and verify if their environment
was set up correctly.
So we can go back to our
demo that wrote, right?
So we wrote this "Rad Demo."
Whoops.
And we can just Flutter run it.
Let's do it in release mode,
so we can use Dart's AOT.
And we'll do it on
our Nexus device.
And so while that
goes ahead and builds,
I'm going to go ahead
and swap back over.
So right now, Flutter is talking
to the underlying toolchain.
And it's, you know, it goes
and gets itself a doughnut,
or whatever the toolchain does.
And then it'll come back
to us with an assigned APK.
And it'll install that
APK on our device.
It looks like it's
finishing up now.
Again, this is not your
development workflow.
But now we have our release
ready to send to the Store app.
That still counts buttons,
running on Android.
Pick it up and take it away.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was a taste of
our developer experience.
There's a whole talk on
our developer experience
after this one.
If you want to
learn more, there's
lots of interesting
details there.
Let's talk about what
we saw-- or maybe it
wasn't all obvious-- one
of the things you did see,
again, is the fast
developer cycle.
We're doing subsecond,
millisecond-measured developer
cycle.
You got to see a little taste
of our functional reactive
framework.
You can learn a lot more
about it in Flutter.io.
But this is just a
modern way to write UIs.
The idea is it simplifies the
data flow in your application.
It's easy for you to understand
where the data is going,
because it always goes from
your model to your view.
You write that code once.
And then, of course, you did
get to see a little bit of the
"to the metal" nature.
We compiled straight to
native code on Android.
We are, of course,
talking to the GPU.
That's part of how we get fast.
But we haven't
just been building
technology for the last year
and a half since we last talked.
We also have been, actually,
shipping this technology,
but just inside Google.
So we are entirely an
open-source project,
but we do know how
important it is
that we have Google customers.
When we talk to externals, who
are like, what apps at Google
are shipping with this?
What apps with Google have
this on the Play Store?
And the answer is,
there's a lot in progress.
But none are shipping today.
But we have had
close relationships
with Google teams.
We've been paving the road
right in front of them
as they've been building out.
We've been working with
them to make sure that we're
building the right thing.
That it's being
battle-hardened as we go.
And one of the teams
that is visiting today,
so I can talk about their app a
little bit, is the Google CRM.
These guys had used Dart
already successfully on the web.
They had also built
themselves an Android app
natively in Java.
And then they came to
Flutter, because they were not
particularly interested in
paying to build another team
to do an iOS app.
They were like, hey,
can we take some
of our Dart knowledge,
our Android familiarity,
and just build for mobile?
And they did.
And they said it
took them, you know,
less time, fewer
engineers, less code.
They got 3x the productivity
versus their Android build-out.
And they also, of course,
got the other OS for free.
[APPLAUSE]
So I should tell you
that we are still
a tech preview, and that's, you
know, for a variety of reasons.
But we're not entirely
ready for all apps.
That's not what I'm
here to tell you today.
We have very much
tested our hypotheses.
We know that the
hard stuff is done.
We're working really on
productionization now.
All the testing-- and make
sure that all our matrices,
all devices, et cetera,
are all covered.
And we do have some big arcs
of work left, some of which
we've started on.
You know, making sure our
accessibility is amazing.
Making sure our
internationalization
is amazing.
Making sure you can develop for
Windows, which I suspect many
in this audience do.
But all of our source
is open on GitHub today.
You can try Flutter today.
You can watch us do development.
And, of course, there's more
to learn about Flutter today.
There's not just this talk.
There's more about our dev
cycle in the next talk.
They talk about
all the cool stuff
that was built in
Dart to make Flutter
possible at later talks.
And you're hearing from one of
our customers this afternoon.
So I hope you agree that we've
made some significant progress
since we last talked.
There's no more spinning cubes.
We're a little past that.
I hope that you
better understand
after this talk how our
approach to mobile is different.
We're not using OEM widgets.
You know, we're doing
direct to the metal.
And we believe
that this provides
us some unique advantages.
And I also hope
that you understand
that even though you don't
see it in the wild yet,
Flutter is actively
at use in Google.
There are lots of people
writing Flutter code.
And you can learn a
lot more at Flutter.io.
So thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]